hey what's up what's up what's up thank  you very much for for coming out to see  this Suicide Squad has just opened  around the world and is breaking box  office records everywhere we had a  really spectacular time making this film  it's a beautiful room too right look at  that don't forget with the bad guys I  love this guy one of the things I really  love is when you look at the cast it's  so many different races and creeds and  colors is just a beautiful rainbow of  humanity I'm very humbled and honored by  the reception and thank you very much  and with no further ado ladies and  gentlemen I present to you  suicide swamp  I want to build a team with some very  bad people who I think can do some good  y'all Joker's must be crazy